now in this one I just said what is the
worst flag that you've seen when first
dating I didn't make it gender specific
so that was open to everybody so I
wanted to see what people would say we
GNA get the gals to chime in or what
would happen anyway turned up high and
drunk on our first date then proceeded
to shout and curse the staff at the bar
quit and experience I left yeah it's
just look guys you
know I'm going to be completely honest
with you when I started the ladies night
project and if you're not watching that
podcast series it's on Wednesday nights
at 8:00
p.m. I had higher hopes for the caliber
and the quality of women that we would
be able to invite onto the show as
guests um we're not looking for
difficult women like moff does all the
recruiting I you know we've had convers
conversation we're not looking like
we're looking for what you're going to
see out there right granted from time to
time you know you'll see p a couple of
only fans uh girls on but it's it's rare
now like the last show was the last one
that we did it and to be honest with you
that Jasmine character was a colossal
waste of time just a [__] train wreck
um it's not a good um sample size but
the sample size that we've seen from the
months of the other shows the caliber
and quality of women out there that you
have available to you they're not good
you know I've said this many times
you're going to dig through a lot of
dirt before you find gold when it comes
to dating um spin play
date them simultaneously in a non-
monogamous fashion uh let the cream rise
to the top let her come to you and say
hey Rich where do we stand I dig your
Vibe I don't want to share you I want to
claim you I'm not seeing anybody else
other guys are invisible to me you know
what I've been talking about this sort
of stuff then that's when you can at
that point make a decision you can
evaluate her against the red flags again
if you want to see them Aller Below on
the email list you're going to evaluate
her against red flags and if it's low To
None then you can make a decision that
time and say look you know I dig your
Vibe too but let's say for example she's
posting thirst traps on social media not
all the time but sometimes enough that
it's a problem but I can't take a gal
seriously that posts you know sexy
provocative pictures on social media
you're not using it for business uh
you're only using it to get attention
and likes and uh you know comments from
guys so can you knock it off because
then I might be able to take you
seriously sort of thing right that's how
you handle you know situations like that
but you're going to dig through a lot of
dirt before you find something that
looks like gold and you know like a
woman like that might say well get
[__] I'm not going to do that okay you
made this very simple for me bye right
I've got other options you know we'll
see how those pan out sort of thing or
she may say you know what you're
absolutely right a woman in a serious
relationship with a guy that she adores
and loves and of course you know you
know you're looking at from your
perspective yes she has genuine burning
desire for me and all that sort of stuff
she'll she'll delete her social media
she'll shut it off if she admires adores
and loves you she will trust me I
know um let's see what else we got
here yeah so here's another one massive
lack of accountability personal
accountability I used to do this um you
know from time to time if I was on a
date with a chick and she was all my ex
the government the you know my employer
my boss everybody's an [__] everybody
does them wrong my parents my you know
my sister doesn't matter what it happens
to be it's everybody else's fault but
hers I would just look at her in the eye
and be like cool so what role did you
play in this like how could you have
made that better how could you have
avoided that situation right like
basically asking them well what's your
role in this equation what did you do to
contribute to this [__] show right like
where's the accountability uh if she
doesn't take accountability again it's
not long-term relationship material it's
very simple guys this is why I say date
a bunch of women simultaneously in a
non- monogamous fashion the cream will
rise to the top and the stuff that's not
the will just fall down right the plates
will fall down and smash do whatever you
want with that
right when she tells you she's not fully
over her ex that's Alpha widowed again
that's in my red flag
list um they don't always jump back to
them given the chance if he comes back
they may
um usually when a chick's Alpha Widow
it's it's because she couldn't secure
him so he walked on her so they they
generally don't want anything to do with
them which speaks volumes like why would
like if she's such a great chick if
she's selling herself to you like I'm
such a great catch and if this guy
walked away from her then why I would
even ask that question
so I mean she's already telling you that
you know she's Alpha widowed at that
point so why not play along don't
explain what an alpha Widow is or that
you you recognized that trade in her
that doesn't do anything it's a waste of
your time don't try to Red Pill women or
any of that [__] that's what dorks do
but oh so why did he leave you if you're
so
great and then just sit there and wait
for her to answer
right we talked about daddy issues uh
victim is another one that's on my red
flag list you know women that are always
uh unhappy UNL unhappy or unlucky they
have a victim mindset about
everything um frustrated because of work
I don't talk to my parents very often
yeah a lot of these we've already
covered I was chatting up a young lady
at party and she fored me she was
intimidating to men her parents were
both dead her son is a result of a rape
10 years earlier true story she's
intimidating to men that's a boss girl
that's a chick that wants to compete
with you
like intimidating
how there look unless you're dating a
chick that's a say like I'm 6'2 like
unless I'm dating a chick that's 6'2 of
[__] Amazon which I don't because I'm
not attracted to [__] Sasquatches I
want to date women that are feminine and
in you know like in feminine stature
right I don't want a chick that weighs
200 pounds you can't pick them
up why would she be intimidating to us
as men I mean to me anyway that's that's
just how I roll but why would a chick
tell me I mean I can't imagine a chick
sitting across me from a date five
between 55 and 5 eight n or something
like that and going well I intimidate
men how
exactly I've seen legitimately scary
[__] dudes I've never been
intimidated by like even an MMA fighter
like Ronda Rousey she would not
intimidate me I'd be like I mean most
average guys of of you know height and
weight could
proba intimidate me come on let's let's
move on from that while I appreciate her
honesty she flat out told me that she's
high maintenance and believe that if a
man did not spoil her financially that
she would consider him cheap how about
get [__]
yeah I will spend my money and time and
attention on you as I see fit you don't
get to tell me what I have to do that's
a that's an immediate get [__] why
because you have other options because
you generally have better options than
that high maintenance all that high
maintenance means is that she's a [__]
generally speaking is that she's going
to be difficult she's going to nag you
she's going to chat she's going to
criticize
you just
don't admitted that she cheated on her
husband with a virtual bum a valet at a
hospital that was 10 years younger a
liar alcoholic friend I was an idiot she
was a pump and ghost but I fell for her
BS I cheated on my husband make me your
wife
okay it took took place where I lived in
Alaska got back into dating went to a
nice late afternoon coffee date home
girl didn't work I was cool with it
first half of the date goes well very
respectful and well put together we see
the northern lights are out and decided
to go for a cool spot to take a light
show this is a little story I didn't
have a four-wheel drive vehicle at the
time it was nice it was snowing so we
hop on her brand so we hopped in her
brand new SUV nice we get to the
outskirts of town and she starts
hysterically crying and breaking this
character she was in it was some real
life stuff from movie Split turns out
she was schizophrenic and planning to
kill me because my appearance look like
the guy that hurt her as a child holy
smokes I
mean generally speaking you want to be
in control of the situation and the date
because you don't know what you're
dealing with like you could be dealing
with some legit crazy chick I'll tell
you a story in a second
um yeah like you want to be in your own
vehicle I even go to the extent like if
I sit in a restaurant I usually sit
where I can see the entrance like this
is something that I learned in caga
right like you want situational
awareness you sit where your back's up
against the wall you're looking at the
you know the entrances and the exit sort
of thing you just know what's going on
right it's from my motorcycle days I
talk about in the book why it's a good
idea for men to own a motorcycle and you
know detail all the reasons for that
and it's one of the things that I
learned while you know being a
motorcyclist you have to keep your head
on a swivel you have to know what's
around you have to have situational
awareness um I would have probably
sniffed out crazy before I got anywhere
near her vehicle um but if you're going
to plan to go anywhere you should be
driving that's just my take on it oh
that's story yeah let me share that
story and then we'll get to the calling
Q&A in a second so let's pull this out
here speaking of
crazy had this date once with this um
with this gal she was hot kind of a
fitness gal you know that's that's what
I'm attracted to like a fitness girl
right curves pretty um you know in shape
but not muscular not like dude looking
like like a bikini model type of look so
she ticked off th those boxes blah blah
blah we're talking you know standard
sort of stuff that I would do around the
time grab a coffee go for a stroll you
know open park somewhere lots of
sunlight lots of air lots of people
around she's comfortable you go sit down
somewhere you're chatting she goes have
you ever been in the back of a police
car and I'm thinking to myself that's an
interesting question I've never been
asked
that I and I go wait have you ever been
in the back of a police car I'm
wondering why she's asking me the
question and then this is when she
starts singing like a canary well there
was the one time when I was trying to
talk to my boyfriend and he locked me
out of the house and I picked up a log
that was stacked at the side of the
house that he would use for firewood and
I threw it through the front window and
I ended up in the back of the police car
and I spent a few hours in jail I'm like
okay yeah like ask questions
guys women will sing like a canary if
you ask some questions they love talking
give them the opportunity give them the
soapbox the stage and hear what they're
all about because that again that's what
your that's what your date is about it's
a sniff test you want to see what she's
made of you want to see what she's about
is this a chick that I want to spend you
know more than one date with because the
whole problem with like the Mano swamp
and the Pua culture and all this
[__] they're like get the same day
lay it's like
sure but if you're a guy with options
and you have
abundance you've got a phone which also
has options in it and if you're single
and you're dating non monogamously if
you want to get late it's pretty easy
okay so the whole like push for the same
date lay you could invite a Nutter into
your freaking house you could end up
going back to her house and wake up in a
bathro tub with ice around you missing a
kidney I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out